foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Wilburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together
we're the minimalist we're here with
malabama hi everybody TK Coleman Frosty
the Snowman
look at the rest of our team here in the
studio as well coming up today on this
free public minimal episode we're
talking to a listener about wanting to
let go and we've got our exciting
lightning round segment for you we've
got a question about deprivation in
there a live stream question for you and
a listener tip you can check out the
full two-hour maximal edition of episode
391 where we answer five times the
questions and we dive deep into several
simple living segments that private
podcast episode is out right now at
patreon.com the minimalists your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
100 advertisement free because say with
me y'all advertisements
yes indeed let's start with our callers
today if you have a question or comment
for our show give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice recording
to podcast at the minimalists.com our
first question today is from Ginny
hi this is Jenny from Kentucky I'm a
minimalist simpleton when I was growing
up I was surrounded by animals dogs cats
rabbits chickens at 12 years old I got
my first horse and have had one ever
since for over 40 years I do love
animals and considered becoming a
veterinarian
I had a head start on minimalism when my
husband died three years ago and I moved
twice since then each time I threw away
or gave away things left by my husband
or two grown children Sporting Goods
office accessories clothes books
vacation souvenirs I had to deal with
almost 40 Years of accumulation
but now I continue to shed things that
somehow got missed before overall I am
doing quite well getting down to what I
need rather than what I want it is slow
but sure and Goodwill and I have become
good friends one problem
all the paraphernalia that belongs to
pets and horses
for my dog and cat there are feeding
bowls grooming tools shampoos and sprays
leashes and collars medicines winter
coats litter boxes treats and food on
and on
and horses are worse when you've owned
them for so long I sold my horse last
year but the barn is full of buckets
blankets grooming tools feed bins fly
sheets temporary electric fence bridles
Saddles halters ropes and all kinds of
specialty accessories
if I give away or sell these items it
means I have made the decision not to
have a horse anymore this decision
weighs on my mind since horses have been
a part of my life and identity for so
many years
so I keep all this stuff around thinking
maybe someday I'll need it again
I'm not sure I can give up at least the
possibility that I will ride again
as a new minimalist the Clutter that
these pet accessories create are getting
in the way of me Breaking Free of
possessions what does an animal lover do
Jenny I totally identify with you I too
have been surrounded by these animals my
entire life
Jenny you can send all your treats to
the minimalists at uh 8322
Beverly Boulevard it looked like he was
looking at you like like kind of like
home alone you filthy animal he's like
I've been surrounded by these animals
so there's an interesting story that I
hear behind this because when I first
heard this I thought it was a question
about letting go of pet accessories but
it's not that at all it's the the pet
accessories are a stand-in for the story
We Tell ourselves I'm letting go of this
piece of my identity yeah and there's a
good reason to do that right because
wherever you want to go meaning what you
actually want is being impeded by what
you think you might want right because
people often give up what they want
to get what they think they want yeah
because I'll get what I want right now
and what I want right now is the story
that I'm clinging to that maybe someday
in some non-existent hypothetical future
I will once again be a horse person and
if I let go of these things what happens
I'm no longer that person well of course
that's not true because let's say today
you let go of all of them and you felt
the amazing relief their spontaneous
combustion you've you've they've gone up
and smoke and now they're gone and now
you feel the relief of letting go of
those things but five years from now you
want to get a horse guess what you still
have access to getting those things
again via the same means that you sold
them by the way let's say you sell them
on eBay or Craigslist or maybe just give
them away somewhere you can pick those
things back up again if they serve you
in the future but you don't have to
carry them into that future and let them
weigh you down in the meantime yet
nothing robs us of our ability to be
playful uh
how do I say that nothing robs us of our
ability to be playful quite like the
commitment to making everything
permanent right like if I let this go I
have to let it go forever if I get rid
of this book that means I'm deciding
forever to never read the book no matter
how I feel in the Future No Matter What
inspires me no matter what I want to do
at some later date I am permanently
committing to do this we even do this
when we pick majors in college if I pick
to major in this now I am choosing
forever to love this and do this and the
most liberating thing we can remember is
we have the permission to change our
minds the you that puts it down is the
same you that can pick it back up and so
you can let things go without
subscribing to a story of permanence
giving away your possessions now is a
reality giving away your possessions
forever is a story that binds you to
some
it it separates you from your
possibilities yeah I think that's a good
point Ryan I I'm thinking about what she
said with respect to Goodwill has become
her good friend but then she's
identified this other clutter that she's
not willing to give up to Goodwill or
the pet equivalent uh of Goodwill yeah
right and so as TKA said she's bound
herself to these things which removes
you from the possibility you mentioned
the book because I think that's an easy
one I've actually gotten rid of books
before and then not regretted it but
then realized like oh I want to read
that book again and guess what I did I
went to the library and I got a copy of
it or I went to my local independent
Bookshop and bought a copy of it again
and I had the ability to read it again
the last thing I'll say here is you know
what
a lot of things she let go of were
probably sentimental but I don't hear
any sentimental attachment to these
things yeah and so you don't have to
deal with the fact that you might be
sentimentally tied to this in fact you
are tied to them even though you don't
want to be you're holding on to
something that you really wish you could
put down well how do you put it down you
just you stop clinging let me tell you
about Orion Nicodemus who embraced
frisbee golf
so let me tell you I used to love
regular golf okay like I had some sweet
clubs sweet bag
um took some lessons was never amazing
at it but uh really enjoyed it and then
I heard about frisbee golf and I'm like
oh that must be for the losers who can't
play regular golf so I uh uh never
touched it I I looked at frisbee golf
like it was lesser than and eventually
got to a point in my uh my golf hobby
life where I just I could not hang on to
these clubs anymore so um I I let those
go and my wife we were in Montana last
summer and she was uh you know trying to
talk me into playing frisbee golf and
I'm like no because my identity is as a
golfer and I'm not gonna give it up and
a long story short well I uh I went with
her to play
um just one round of frisbee golf and
absolutely loved it yeah and I was like
oh wow I've really been depriving myself
of like playing this sport because of
this identity that I I had wrapped up as
a golfer again horrible golfer much
better frisbee golfer but my point is is
that once you um once you start clinging
to an identity hey like you're holding
yourself from moving forward in other
areas of life and sometimes that
identity that you're so wrapped up with
if you let it go actually might might be
okay and you might actually enjoy life a
little bit better when you do let go of
that identity so I guess that's my way
of saying Jenny give Frisbee golf a
chance
well think about that let's let's carry
that forward a little bit more imagine
if every time you went to go play
Frisbee golf now you had to bring those
golf clubs with you and carry them on
your back right that's where Ginny is
right now she's carrying her golf clubs
into frisbee golf and wondering why it's
not as enjoyable yeah it's not as
enjoyable because you're occurring
forward the things from the past that no
longer serve you and it's okay to let go
yeah
you know um it's interesting when you
think about this this dilemma here
because
see you know sometimes you need to give
yourself the chance to see what happens
to an interest when it's not staring you
in the face if the only time you like
want to do something is when you're
looking at possessions related to it
then that might be valuable information
about what your real relationship to
that thing is so with the books for
example I had books that I kept around
for a long time because they're part of
that fantasy reading list but one day
I'm gonna want to read that right one
day and then when I got rid of them the
desire to read them left it's like oh
okay the desire to read it actually came
from having The Possession staring me in
the face every day but once it's gone
the passion to read it is no longer
there now there are some other books
where that passion still remained after
some time but you better believe it when
I got the book back I actually read it
because I appreciated it so sometimes
you have to let things go in order to
see where you really stand in relation
to them yeah and that willingness to let
go Jenny that is a superpower and it's
almost like when I have an opportunity
to
um let go of different things whether
it's a physical possession or whether
it's an identity or a physical
possession that is wrapped up in an
identity that I associate with uh either
I take like uh not Pride but I take it
as a challenge to like just loosen my
grip on these things and I'll tell you
um Jenny like that is the most freeing
thing in the world when you can loosen
your grip when you can let go and as you
said TK it's like if it's really really
meant to be it'll come back around to
you Jenny and you will you will go back
out and and get whatever you need to go
ride horses but uh yeah clinging
certainly is not the way to
um motivate yourself to take on this
this identity of riding a horse that
clinging is just going to if anything
it's going to stilt you I feel like and
it's freeing in one sense but at the
same time it's also terrifying and I
think that's where she is right now
letting go of something can be
terrifying it's kind of like a newborn
baby they're naked and free and
absolutely terrified they're brand new
to this world it's a rebirth for Ginny
letting go of these things and so yes
there will be some fear in that and next
week we're actually talking to Julian
Smith about fear and and how we Flinch
at all of these things that we don't
necessarily need to Flinch at and when
I'm thinking about Ginny and her
clinging here quite often it's easy for
us to let go of something that has never
served us that we'd never get have any
really meaning meaning to if you have a
drawer full of pins and there's one
that's all dried up and there's no more
ink in it no one's like well most people
aren't like oh I could never let go of
this old blue Bic pin you just Chuck it
in the trash yeah I can't let go of it
otherwise I'll never be a writer right I
mean even yeah and and the same thing is
true here where it's like if I let go of
this it functionally has the same thing
it does the same thing as letting go of
that cheap Bic blue pin you're just
getting something out of the way that no
longer serves you that's right it's
getting something out of the way and so
many times we hold on to things with a
narrative of just in case because we're
afraid to pay some hypothetical price in
the future should we need it back but in
exchange for uh doing that we pay a
health price in the present we say
because uh I might have to pay some
hypothetical price in the future I'm
just going to be unhealthy and unhappy
Now by keeping a bunch of things around
that are making me feel heavy Bama you
got something you want to say yeah I
grew up around horses I'm not someone
who handled them myself but I wanted to
offer up another suggestion because what
I hear Jenny talking about uh as
Goodwill not really being a practical
option you don't really donate horse
equipment there because it is such a
specialty kind of thing one thing she
could do is reach out to people in her
local equine Community people that have
ranches in her area and if she's not
ready to donate those start a
conversation with some of those folks
say hey I have some stuff I'm not using
right now but I might want it later is
this something that you could use and
see if it's something that would benefit
them to give it on loan that way you you
have that option to bring it back in
should you decide you want to go riding
again but worst case scenario you give
it to someone who can use it right now
and who who can really benefit from that
horses are used in a lot of therapy
practices nowadays and there's a lot of
Rehabilitation
areas to kind of help some horses that
that had been abused and neglected get
back on their feet by really good people
and I think that'd be a great way to
connect connect with your community just
a thought yeah that's good that's good
where I live up in Ojai the local Humane
Society where you usually to go adopt
cats and dogs also has horses that you
can adopt really that's so cool that's
another option if you live somewhere
that has a Humane Society or Humane
Society equivalent they could certainly
use the equipment by the way it's just
collecting dust and it's not giving you
any value at all but someone else could
get real value from it if you're willing
to let go Jenny I want to give you two
things I'm going to put links to both of
these in the show notes over at the
minimalists.com podcast the first is the
minimalist rule book it's 16 rules for
living with less because what's
happening right now is you're setting up
some boundaries in your life and one of
those boundaries is I'm not holding on
to things that are no longer adding
value they're not enhancing my life and
so there's some rules in there I think
you can apply to not just this horse
equipment and these accessories but
throughout the rest of your life as well
well things like the spontaneous
combustion rule or the seasonality rule
or the 30-day minimalism game and second
we did a whole episode on pets it's
called Simple pets it was episode
329 we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well so Ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the lightning round where we answer your
questions from Tick Tock yes indeed you
can follow the minimalists on Tick Tock
Instagram Facebook and Twitter at the
minimalist during the lightning round we
each have 60 seconds to answer your
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response we put the
text to these minimal maxims in the show
notes over at the minimalists.com
podcast so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like looks like we have a question here
from David it was crazy hearing Aubrey
Marcus talk about being in an isolation
tank are there negative consequences to
depriving yourself like this ah well
give me 60 seconds clear the lane for me
oh no he's already starting to dribble I
need to ISO this
he's already troubling
all right
foreign
's totally missing all the moves that
Ryan was doing he didn't have him on
camera the whole time he was doing that
man that would have been the best giphy
too oh yeah
all right all right David here's what I
have to say to you
short-term deprivation is a spotlight
for Value what Aubrey Marcus was talking
about in that Tick Tock video that
David's commenting about here is when we
deprive ourselves for a period of time
it helps us understand what is useful to
us what is valuable to us what is access
to us what is getting in the way what
will serve us what enhances my life what
downgrades my life what upgrades my life
the only way we can understand that is
if we remove it for a period of time to
truly see the value now there's an
extreme version of this and it's putting
yourself in sensory deprivation for six
days straight you don't have to do that
to temporarily deprive yourself so you
can figure out what you actually value
ladies and gentlemen Ryan Nicodemus we
got 60 seconds oh
um
isolation is not deprivation
it is uh very similar to what Josh was
talking about here when we take
something out of our life when we
especially when it comes to
um this isolation that Aubry Marcus was
talking about where he literally went
into darkness he had no sound he could
uh basically feel around and stick his
hand in some avocado toast and know that
that's where his food was and eat and be
sustained
um but taking that away for a temporary
period of time is not deprivation that
is something that allows us to really uh
get clear on what we appreciate so I can
only imagine like the um the the last
day there where he's brought out and
complete darkness and given the light
and how much more he appreciated just
that that sense that he uh that he took
for granted I think it's spot on so as a
metaphor
it's showing you the benefits of the
light the things that we take for
granted we can temporarily deprive
ourselves but it doesn't mean you get
rid of it forever Aubry Marcus didn't go
there yeah and say you know what I'm
giving up all sensory perception for the
rest of my life yeah but hey let me let
me find the gratitude that already
exists that I've covered up with
overindulgence yeah that's right that's
right all right nothing is more
dangerous than a confrontation with your
true self the ultimate game of hide and
seek is the one that is taking place
every day between the roles that we play
in order to fit in be a normally human
being and that more substantial
spontaneous self lying underneath the
surface waiting for the opportunity to
shine through when you use ascetic
discipline to connect with that Deeper
Self that is the complete opposite of
deprivation that is self-liberation that
is self-actualization it is only when
you Embrace a path of deprivation
because of some worship of pain as an
intrinsic good that you lose your way
change feels dangerous only because
Extinction is the price you have to pay
for evolution in order to become the
person you truly want to be you might
have to let some of these roles that
make you familiar and secure die and
that feels dangerous but only because
you're coming to life that preaches
we're gonna check in with the live
stream here in a moment but first real
quick for right here right now here's
one very exciting thing that's going on
in the life of the minimalists we for
the first time ever are launching a
decluttering course yes 67 ways to
declutter your closet just kidding
it is called simplify everything
and we start it's five weeks we start
with the stuff but then and we help you
simplify the stuff
get rid of the excess stuff identify the
excess stuff provide some boundaries
some rules some tools some solutions to
let go but that's just the first week
the other four weeks are identifying all
of these other forms of clutter for
example relationship clutter or calendar
clutter or digital clutter or money or
financial clutter all of these different
types of clutter that are cluttering our
lives beyond the stuff it's five weeks
total it's 17 video lessons 45 clutter
problem areas
135 decluttering Solutions a 30-page
workbook and of course student Forum so
you can have access to other people who
are taking the course the same time as
you and much much more the course
Launches on May 29th 2023 and it's open
for 72 hours only you can enroll for 72
hours starting May 29th so what I want
you to do is head on over to simplify
everything.xyz someoneparked on the.com
so don't go there simplify
everything.xyz and just there's a
landing page there right now put your
email address in that box whatever send
you spam or junk or advertisements
obviously but we'll let you know as soon
as the course opens up it'll be open for
72 hours and over the course of five
weeks we've spent months and months and
months preparing this filming this
re-filming this re-re-filming this at
this point to create something that is
Meaningful and Lasting for you there's a
lot there we're going to help you
simplify everything simplify
everything.xyz to get more information
Alabama let's check in with the patreon
live stream what do you got for us we
have a comment here that came from a
patron Kristen she said one of your
controversial guests might have saved my
health in 2017 during my third pregnancy
we with my mother dying of cancer I was
looking for ways to better my own health
and avoid her fate enter the plant-based
diet I remained vegetarian until 2021
when I lost my dad and I got so
depressed that I stopped carrying what I
ate naturally this caused some weight
issues for me and a few months ago I
decided to return to my vegetarian diet
to help get back to a healthier weight I
hadn't been eating a ton of meat the
last two years but I felt like cutting
it out was still a good place to start
so there I am a few weeks in feeling
like crap thinking it's just a hiccup
and I'll get past it when you guys have
Dr Paul saladino on the show it took me
several days to listen to that episode
because frankly I just didn't agree with
anything he was saying but after I
finally finished it I decided to get
blood work done and go into my horror my
ferritin levels were a nine who knows
how long they had been that low it's no
wonder I felt terrible all the time I
abandoned the plant-based diet and
bought a bottle of grass-fed beef liver
capsules the difference in my energy
levels have been life-changing PS I'm so
excited you guys added TK to the show
that's awesome that's awesome we're
excited too hey Kristen I here's what
I'll say is you know we had the segment
where we talked about many of our most
controversial guests we don't even
realize they're controversial until
after the fact yeah and people often are
frustrated because they think it's some
sort of prescription like we're saying
we bring someone on like Dr Paul
saladino or we bring on Rich Roll who's
a very healthy vegan athlete he's been a
vegan for 16 years and I say wow that
seems to really work well for him and he
has some great insights about that it
doesn't mean I'm prescribing veganism to
anyone I'm also not prescribing the
animal based or whatever Paul saladino
is doing as well but what I love about
this by bringing on different people
like that or people like Joanne
Cacciatore or Dr Nicole lepera these
people who are often perceived to be
controversial after the fact what is it
does is it creates a spotlight for
people to start looking intrinsically
they look at their own life and say yeah
huh that recipe they're sharing might I
benefit from that and if the answer is
no that's okay I don't need to be
dogmatic and and renounce it I simply
don't have to take it on if I don't get
any value from it yeah that's right one
of the hardest things to do in life is
to give yourself permission to say
something in a world where you and
everyone else knows that what you say
isn't going to apply to everyone and it
isn't going to work for everyone and so
we we try to clean it up with
preferences like with prefaces like hey
this isn't for everyone or hey this is
one way of looking at it but then you
can only spend so much time saying that
before you just become a person who is
constantly hemming and Hauling and you
know hedging and you never actually say
anything there's nothing more boring to
listen to than just an hour of now this
is just one of many possible ways to
look at it and you know this could be
offensive if you you see it a certain
way but if we carefully Define the terms
here now it's like hey man can you just
say something yes can you take the risk
of saying something and sometimes we
have people on it's not so much
promoting their ideas because like you
said ritual
and Paul saladino opposite viewpoints
and you even had a show where they're
debating it's about putting the ideas
out there having conversations and
knowing that it's going to help some
people and other people are going to say
it's not for me and it's all good but
thank you for sharing your story because
uh I think it's good for people to hear
that that everything that might strike
you as a total waste of time could be
the very thing that's setting someone
else free and as she said it might have
saved her life that's not why we did the
episode but what a beautiful byproduct
of that yeah I like having people on the
show that I don't necessarily agree with
because it helps me do one or two things
either one it helps me change my
perspective and understand people a
little bit more or it uh helps me be
seated even further into whatever value
belief that is being tested and either
way like that is a benefit for me
um yeah could you imagine if we had all
the right answers what a responsibility
that would be a man to have only the
right answers and that's the only thing
that we could talk about on this show
were right answers only I used to but
they were all wrong right yeah
we've got a bunch more questions from
the patreon live stream we'll check back
in in a minute but first i'm Alabama
what else you got for us here's a
minimalist Insight from one of our
listeners
hey Josh hey Ryan uh there's a quote
that I found recently that I've been
implementing into my life to really help
me
it goes as follows
treat everyone with politeness even
those who are rude to you not because
they are nice but because you are
all right y'all that's our minimal
episode today we'll see you on patreon
for the full two hour maximal edition of
episode 391 which includes answers to a
bunch more questions questions like how
can I get my kids to want to minimize
donate and let go how do you convince
someone that antique is not a synonym
for junk and how do you distinguish just
in case items from just for win items
plus a million more questions for the
minimalists also this week a private
minimalist home tour from our friend
Kristen Ziegler at Minima remember last
week we had her on the podcast this is
my favorite home tour to date I aspire
to have my home look like her home we're
gonna we're gonna take you inside her
home with six different photos
throughout all that and much much more
of less and if you want to hear all that
check out the minimalist private podcast
this week visit patreon.com the
minimalist or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain access to all of
our podcast archives all the way back to
episode zero zero one if you're still on
the fence here's a testimonial from one
of our lovely patreon subscribers Sean
Smith says I joined again
I learned so much from you guys I listen
to the private podcast every day it's so
calming initially your Netflix specials
hooked me but now I don't follow y'all
for minimalism but for the great
conversations I think that's really what
the private podcast does it allows us to
have these free-flowing long-form deeper
conversations to answer a lot more of
your questions it gives us the space
when I say the safe space to have
conversations we wouldn't necessarily
have in public Sean thanks for your
comment for your testimonial there if
you all leave here today with just one
message please let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all see you next time
peace
every little thing
y every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it